donc accoster ce weekend à Toulon avec à
son bord plus de 200 migrants qui ont
été accueillis sur la prescrit de géant
seront examiner leur dossier de
sénateurs se sont rendus hier dans ce
son de Samia de Schir les a suivi on
regarde son reportage
après 3 semaines d'attente en mer c'est
d'abord un sentiment de soulagement les
234 migrants de l'océan Viking ont
débarqué ce week-end dans le port de
Toulon avant d'être provisoirement
accueilli dans ce centre de vacances de
la presqu'île de Gien blessé au bras cet
homme originaire de Guinée a été l'un
des premiers évacués par hélicoptère
donc les femmes aussi donc
c'était pas facile moi je m'entendais
pas à ça parce que
deux ou trois jours on pourra avoir
rester dans bateau jusqu'à trois
semaines on regardait réel sauf l'eau on
voit personne
sauf le quand même c'est un peu ça nous
a trop effray c'est notre triste des
Bouches-du-Rhône Marie Arlette Carlotti
s'est invitée sur les lieux pour
connaître les réelles conditions
d'accueil des migrants la prise en
charge est assurée par 25 bénévoles de
la Croix Rouge nombre d'entre eux sont
arrivés pieds nus par exemple torse nu
donc mise à disposition de vêtements et
là la distribution va continuer au jour
nourriture logement soin médicaux les
conditions de vie semblent correctes
mais les naufragés de l'océan Viking
n'ont pas vocation à rester ici ils vont
faire l'objet d'une procédure accélérée
derrière ces tentes les agents de
l'OFPRA l'Office français de protection
des réfugiés et apatrides ont 48 heures
pour entendre chacun des 234 migrants
la petite fenêtre plastique on a vu un
monsieur complètement penché sur un
téléphone je suppose pour essayer
d'entendre la traduction donc là aussi
ça me paraît compliqué de pour lui de
c'est terrible il nous a fait coucou
d'ailleurs en passant parce que c'est là
vous pouvez pas insister pour avoir des
interprètes ici et maintenant là vous
parce que c'est votre boulot et c'est
pas possible de travailler comme ça
pardon tout le monde je pense que le
dispositif a été mis en place en effet
très vite on a essayé de répondre à la
situation après de manière générale
l'entretien frontière se fait avec un
interprète par téléphone des entretiens
menés en urgence pour décider qui sera
autorisé à déposer une demande d'asile
j'ai pu constater effectivement qu'il
n'avait pas de recours aux avocats on
leur dit mais ne demande pas mais est-ce
qu'ils savent même qu'ils peuvent le
demander les signalements ici les
informations sont en français à part les
Maliens très peu par le Français cette
procédure accélérée d'examen des
dossiers et due à une décision de la
préfecture du Var celle de créer ici une
zone d'attente internationale pour
accueillir les naufragés de l'océan
Viking
techniquement ils n'ont pas encore mis
un pied sur le sol français et non pas
le droit de quitter le centre une autre
solution aurait pu être trouvée c'est à
dire favoriser l'accueil et ne pas
enfermer les gens les accueillir
directement les accueillir pleinement
sur le territoire et les permettre
notamment de faire de faire valoir leurs
droits et notamment le droit à la
protection au titre de l'asile de
manière plus sereine et dans le cas de
procédures normales en cas de refus les
migrants auront 48 heures pour déposer
un recours avant d'être éventuellement
reconduit dans leur pays d'origine les
autres pourront enfin officiellement
entrer sur le sol français pour déposer
une demande d'asile
la France s'est engagée à accueillir un
tiers des demandeurs les autres seront
pris en charge par d'autres pays
européens
ou sont donc accueillis ces migrants
marées Carlotti bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous c'est natrices
socialistes des Bouches-du-Rhône vous
avez dans leur portage chez vous qui
vous êtes rendu hier dans ce centre
d'abord un mot pourquoi vous avez
souhaité vous y rendre
et bien avec mon collègue on a décidé de
faire valoir le droit de visite comme
tous les parlementaires dans des sommes
d'attente et donc je pensais qu'il était
urgent d'y aller mais pas forcément sur
le port pour gesticuler pour et pour
faire une contre manifestation à
l'extrême droite non mais y aller de
façon sereine les rencontrer et voir
dans quelles conditions ils étaient
hébergés chez nous alors on voit dans le
reportage les conditions ont l'air
satisfaisantes vous nous le confirmez
oui totalement les conditions sont
satisfaisantes bien sûr le centre de
vacances et correct alors je précise que
ce n'est pas un 5 étoiles comme
certaines de mauvaises langues ont voulu
le dire il est sommaire mais il est
totalement correct la protection civile
fait un travail considérable en matière
de logistique puisqu'ils entretiennent
les lieux il livre de la nourriture
enfin vous l'avez vu même des vêtements
grâce aux associations qui se mobilisent
dans tout le Var et la Croix Rouge est
omniprésente et les accompagne oui ça va
pour ceux que ce point de vue ça va
Marianne si vous pouvez rester avec nous
quelques minutes on va faire réagir et
Pierre la France a eu raison elle a bien
géré l'accueil de ces migrants pour vous
Yves elle était au pied du mur elle
pouvait pas c'était un peu compliqué si
vous voulez mais ce qui est malheureux
là-dedans c'est que moi je ne cesse de
le dire depuis 20 à 25 ans je pense que
tout le monde aurait eu avantage à lire
Jean-Christophe Rufin l'Empire et les
nouveaux barbares il y a 25 ans qui
disait exactement ce qu'on était en
train de vivre ici c'est ce qu'on vit
depuis 25 ans et c'est un défaut complet
de d'anticipation de la part de tous les
gouvernements qui se sont succédés une
espèce de lâcheté de l'Europe qui a
jamais réussi à s'entendre sur ce sujet
et c'est vrai que
si vous voulez on est dans une dans une
situation où c'est chacun pour soi enfin
chaque pays
gris il l'entend ce sujet et c'est même
pas un sujet humanitaire je vais vous
dire c'est pas un sujet humanitaire il
faut qu'on arrête avec ça parce que qui
veut mettre des gens à la mer personne
c'est un sujet éminemment politique
madame Meloni est fait de la politique
monsieur Macron il fait de la politique
et tous les autres font de la politique
me en Angleterre aussi c'est de la
politique et il faudrait un jour que
cette politique et bien elle soit
harmonisée et qu'elle prenne en compte
justement le la distorsion de
développement qu'il y a entre le sud de
notre planète et le Nord on va venir sur
la question européenne et sur l'Italie
mais sur l'accueil de ces migrants en
France Pierre oui je re même sur le
citation de de Ruffin parce que je crois
que l'ÉRIC Zemmour là aussi cité
récemment pour expliquer aux Français
que il y avait aujourd'hui
je me souviens hier ou avant-hier Rick
Zemmour si tu es faim nous expliquant
aujourd'hui oui on nous expliquant
qu'aujourd'hui Ruffin avait dit que la
France serait la France la France serait
envahi par 2 milliards 2 à 3 milliards
d'Africains dans les quelques années qui
arrivent quand on sait qu'il y a à peu
près 1 million un milliard un peu plus
de 100000 je crois africains c'est c'est
dire la la la la la colonne vertébrale
qui existe aujourd'hui sur la droite et
l'extrême droite mais moi je suis
mais je me réjouis que Marie-Hélène
Carlos Marilyn Carlos Carlotti pardon a
pu se rendre sur sur ce site parce que
c'est vrai que j'ai cru comprendre qu'un
syndrome de parlementaire qui avait fait
cette demande de pouvoir contrôler les
conditions avec elle était accueillie
aujourd'hui alors j'aime pas dire les
migrants je trouve qu'il y a une
meilleure déshumaniser aussi tout ce qui
se joue à travers ces personnes qui sont
exilés réfugiés de force mais c'est
faisant de voir qu'aujourd'hui les
parlementaires puissent aller vérifier
que les conditions d'accueil sont les
bonnes j'espère qu'elles ont été bonnes
parce que je suis pas sûr que ce soit le
cas aujourd'hui partout en France
notamment dans les centres de rétention
et notamment depuis la Loi de
l'immigration où on peut incarcéré
aujourd'hui des enfants jusqu'à 90 jours
c'est quand même ça la France aussi mais
on y reviendra j'imagine parce que c'est
énormément à dire sur la question de de
des conditions d'accueil on n'est pas
sur une crise des migrants on est sur
une crise de l'accueil aujourd'hui des
réfugiés plus qu'une crise migratoire il
y a pas de crise migratoire en réalité
on va y revenir mais sur ce que disait
Yves Maria Carlotti alors déjà pour
rebondir sur ce que mon père ça n'a pas
été compliqué pour vous de vous rendre à
Gien hier
de toute façon c'est notre droit tous
les parlementaires de France ont le
droit de visiter des zones dites
d'enfermement parce que ils sont quand
même enfermés il y a une centaine de CRS
qui font leur travail et qui le font
bien et correctement dans le site donc
c'est notre droit d'y aller accompagné
de journalistes avec un nombre limité
pour pas être trop voyeuriste et
déranger les la situation ils sont bien
accueillis j'ai quand même constaté
qu'il y avait des problèmes d'accès au
droit puisque ce jour là c'était
présenté mais de façon totalement
spontanée des avocats du Var pour venir
les accompagner on les avait pas
interpellé c'est elle qui sont venus en
disant mais ils ont besoin d'avocat donc
ce que je disais tout à l'heure dans le
dans le reportage il y a des droits
auxquels ils ont ils ont droit à
certains droits mais ils ne le demande
même pas parce qu'ils sont complètement
perdus donc oui et puis quand à la
politique enfin je voudrais réagir quand
à la situation de la France bien sûr
elle a réagi dos mur c'est une question
au départ humanitaire mais franchement
quelle hypocrisie quand même parce que
on prend les migrant on ne peut pas
accepter de les voir mourir en
Méditerranée mais en même temps on dit à
tout le monde attention ils sont sur
leur territoire français mais ils ne
sont pas en France parce qu'il y a la
zone d'attente a été décrétée par le
préfet donc ils ont dans une situation
particulière on va examiner la façon
dont ils peuvent accéder à l'asile de
façon extrêmement rapide beaucoup trop
rapide à mes yeux ils ont certainement
un droit de recours mais à ce stade tout
ça les dépasse totalement et quand on
les regarde ils ont complètement des
étoiles dans les yeux pour eux ils sont
en France ils ont tous demandé l'asile
en France je rappelle que on a utilisé
une autre méthode pour les ukrainiens et
je j'en suis ravie c'est-à-dire qu'on a
utilisé un asile provisoire qui permet
aux Ukrainiens 97000 je crois à peu près
sont arrivés en France sans que ça pose
de problème et c'est bien et tant mieux
et donc du coup on n'a pas utilisé la
même méthode cette fois je pense pas
mais je crois que pour vous cette
décision de créer une zone d'attente
internationale qui fait que ils ne sont
pas considérés comme en France c'est une
décision politique de la part d'Emmanuel
Macron c'est une gestion en même temps
vous voyez on les accueille pour montrer
qu'on est humanitaire humain et c'est
normal et c'est bien et je félicite le
gouvernement français de l'avoir fait
mais de l'autre côté on serre les vis on
serre les vis et je suis d'accord avec
ce qui a été dit tout à l'heure c'est
globalement l'Union européenne qui est
en cause il n'y a aucune solidarité les
directives ne sont pas totalement
respectées la situation est complètement
embolisée il est temps de mettre le
dossier sur la table sauf que ce que je
crains c'est que le dossier soit plutôt
interne à la politique interne avec la
montée des extrêmes droites tout le
monde est frileux et que on ne regarde
pas la situation globale et
internationale quoi qu'il arrive si on
décide d'être extrêmement rigoureux il y
aura des migrants ils sont dans une
situation particulière avec le
réchauffement climatique les problèmes
économiques tout ça nous le savons donc
on doit ouvrir des voies d'immigration
légale contrôlées et de manière à ce que
les personnes vivent dignement sur notre
territoire un mot puisque le
gouvernement répète et vous nous l'avez
redis que cet accueil est exceptionnel
et c'est à titre exceptionnel pour pour
des questions humanitaires qu'est-ce que
vous dites de ça parce que c'est une
situation qui a de grandes chances de se
reproduire
mais c'est pas une situation
exceptionnelle c'est ce que je viens de
dire je rappelle que la dernière fois
ils avaient refusé le gouvernement avait
refusé de recevoir les réfugiés qui
étaient sur l'Aquarius de SOS
Méditerranée aujourd'hui c'était
tellement évident que on ne pouvait pas
continuer à regarder des personnes qui
risquaient de mourir et donc ils ont agi
sous la pression je rappelle et je
remercie d'ailleurs les premiers qui ont
réagi qui sont Gilles siméone et Benoît
Payan à Marseille en Corse qui eux sont
des méditerranéens et qui savent que la
Méditerranée est quand même une mère qui
tue chaque année énormément c'est une
situation politique zigzag du
gouvernement j'espère qu'au niveau aura
plus clair dans le travail que nous
allons faire sur le projet de loi que
propose Darmanin le groupe socialiste
commence à y travailler un dernier mot
puisque hier notamment entre autres
Bruno Retailleau et Jordan Bardella ont
pointé le rôle des ONG je leur donne
Bardella dit qu'il y a une complicité
entre les ONG et les mafia de passeurs
Bruno Retailleau lui dit que cette ONG
sont des sortes d'auxiliaires des
passeurs qu'est-ce que vous dites de ça
je dis que ces ONG sont des vies s'il
parle du SOS Méditerranée c'est un vieux
débat j'en ai toujours en train de leur
dire qu'ils font le rôle des passeurs
non il ramasse des gens à la mer ils
exercent le droit de protéger les
naufragés et c'est un droit
international ils font leur travail et
deuxièmement sur le site du centre de
vacances je regrette qu'il n'y ait pas
des ONG nous avons été accompagnés qui
connaît parfaitement la situation qui
établit des rapports qui qui les
envoient ils sont publiques et il n'y a
pas de stand pour qu'ils soient sur
place de manière à parler au réfugiés à
parler à leur expliquer où ils sont dans
quelle situation ils sont voilà je pense
que c'est une erreur je voulais dire
aussi qu'il y a un stand sur le site et
que j'ai apprécié qui instant tenu par
la police qui interroge de façon
volontaire les gens viennent pour voir
qui sont les passeurs comment ils sont
passés il est parce qu'il y a une
enquête sur place qui est faite pour
détecter les passeurs et ça c'est plutôt
bien merci beaucoup Maria let Carlotti
merci d'avoir été avec nous et merci de
nous avoir permis de vous accompagner
hier lors de la visite de ce centre à
Gien merci d'avoir été avec nous sur les
ONG parce que c'est un débat qui a été
relancé hier par Bruno Retailleau par
Jordan Bardella qui disent qu'ils font
le jeu des passeurs c'est ce que disait
Castanet aussi
écoutez ce qui est sûr c'est que vous
avez aujourd'hui en Méditerranée une
cinquantaine de bateaux qui circulent et
qui vont
repêcher pardon de se taire des des
migrants qui sont à la dérive et qui ont
été abandonnés par les passeurs vous
savez comment ça se passe moi j'y suis
allé c'est très simple vous avez des
passeurs qui prennent sur des canaux qui
qui font 10 km qui font 8 mailles qui
les abandonnent sur des bateaux qui sont
complètement déglinguées
et vous avez des bateaux des bateaux de
des cargos qui passent et qui ramasse
les migrants pour éviter qu'ils
périssent voilà c'est comme ça que ça se
passe alors est-ce qu'on peut considérer
que ce sont des
je dirais des complices oui mais sinon
vous les laissez mourir
mais je veux dire on peut remonter la
chaîne très loin on peut poser la
question à Monsieur Sarkozy pourquoi il
est allé
taper en Libye
est-ce que les Français savent que
l'opération qu'on a fait en Libye ça a
déstabilisé toute l'Afrique de l'Ouest
qu'on a la solution à cela
ça vous pouvez m'en parler parce que
c'est les terrains que je connais bien
bon alors à partir de là qu'est-ce que
vous voulez que c'est quoi la solution
aujourd'hui
c'est pas possible qu'il y ait des
politiques nationales c'est qui est une
politique européenne qui souhaite une
politique extrêmement ferme qui soit une
politique aussi de screening vous savez
ce que c'est que le screening si vous
avez connu le Cambodge ou le Vietnam le
screening c'est qu'on on regarde d'où
viennent les gens je suis désolé ils ont
raison de faire du screening là dans ce
centre voir d'où viennent les gens il y
a des gens qui viennent effectivement
parce que ils sont pourchassés dans leur
pays qui sont des pays de dictature
parce qu'ils sont victimes de la famille
parce qu'ils sont victimes de
de la pauvreté mais vous avez par
ailleurs des gens qui s'infiltrent
là-dedans bon tout ça pour dire quoi
c'est que on est dans moi ce que je veux
pas c'est que en France se crée se
reconstitue à intervalles réguliers ce
qui se passe par exemple porte de la
chapelle avec des des zones ce qui s'est
passé ce qui se passe à Sangatte c'est
absolument
ignominus qui se passe et on devrait se
pencher sur la question au niveau
européen avant de parler de l'Europe un
mot pierre latu et puis sur les
divisions de la classe politique on va
voir ça dans quelques secondes oui mais
il faut remettre un tout petit peu de de
j'allais dire de bon sens je déteste
expression mais je de de rationalité sur
ce que sont les migrations c'est
l'histoire de l'humanité les migration
l'histoire de l'humanité l'histoire des
hommes des femmes ont toujours migrés à
travers le monde et aujourd'hui quand
j'entends les discours comme ceux de
Gérard Collomb hier encore qui nous
expliquait hier mais quand il était
ministre il expliquait qu'il y avait une
submersion migratoire c'est totalement
faux aujourd'hui il y a 80% en 70%, je
crois des migrations qui se font du Sud
vers le sud des pays pauvres vers les
pays pauvres je crois qu'on est je crois
qu'on est pas mais ça se passe mal parce
que on est aussi on est aussi on est
aussi pour partir responsable je ne suis
pas responsable d'être à l'image vous
n'êtes pas responsable d'être né à
Ajaccio vous n'êtes pas responsable
d'être né à homme ce à Bagdad ou
aujourd'hui à give donc ce que je veux
dire c'est qu'à un moment donné
rejoindre un tout petit peu d'humidité
si les gens bougent aujourd'hui c'est
parce qu'on est responsable on est
responsable parce qu'on est responsable
du réchauffement climatique on est
responsable parce qu'on est responsables
les inégalités économiques et sociales
et qui créent des misères pas possible
des famines dans des pays du Sud on est
responsables parce qu'on alimente les
guerres aujourd'hui à travers le monde
et que donc les pays du Nord ont une
dette aussi envers les pays du Sud donc
la question c'est pas tant de savoir
s'il faut financer les ONG la question
c'est de savoir quels sont nos
politiques d'immigration et de migration
parce qu'on est toujours que la gauche
n'a pas de solution sur la question
d'immigration je finis juste là-dessus y
parce que si la gauche a une politique
migratoire elle dit juste qu'il faut
juste il faut simplement mettre des
conditions d'accueil créer les
conditions d'accueil comme Angela Merkel
a pu le faire je suis désolé mais on dit
toujours anglais Merkel ça a créé des
des soubresauts en en Allemagne mais
pardon mais elle a accueilli 1 million
de migrants quand il y a eu la crise en
Syrie elle a fait quoi elle a donné des
cours d'allemand au migrants elle a fait
quoi elle a permis aux migrants de
pouvoir travailler bon bah aujourd'hui
80% d'entre des millions qui a été
accueilli et complètement intégré à la
société allemande sans difficulté aucune
donc faisons on sort d'accueillir
dignement les personnes qui arrivent de
manière forcer parce que personne n'est
content de partir de chez lui jamais et
donc faisons une sorte de bien les
accueillir de les intégrer de leur
proposer du travail et ça sera une
politique migratoire qui sera digne de
notre mode de développement
des Français comme vous en Afrique comme
je vais vous montrer vous allez à Dakar
vous allez à Dakar et de quoi vous
parlez à Dakar dans chaque famille
sénégalaise chaque famille vous
m'entendez bien il faut qu'il y en ait
un qui partent en France c'est culturel
et ici ne part pas en France il y a un
échec dans la famille et il faut qu'il
réussisse en France si réussit pas en
France évidemment il le dira jamais
qu'il échoue parfois ils échouent
parfois ils réussissent je l'ai vécu je
l'ai vécu combien de fois ça
et j'ai aidé là dessus
et bien c'est un problème c'est culturel
il faut arrêter ce genre de pratique
simplement il faut prendre pour ça
prendre du temps il s'agit pas d'être
pas humain il faut être humain
évidemment mais il y a des pratiques
qu'il faut changer et je peux vous veut
dire que toute l'Afrique de l'Ouest
toute l'Afrique de l'Ouest francophone
et
sous cette culture de l'obligation du
passage à Paris
on a entendu la réaction à gauche avec
marionnette Carlotti on va voir les
autres réactions des autres bords
politiques avec en tant qu'ami
c'est un débarquement inédit vendredi
qui continue de faire polémique la
décision d'accueillir le chêne Viking
était une première pour la France avant
même l'arrivée du bateau en rade de
Toulon
Eric Zemmour avait annoncé se rendre sur
place face à la presse le matin du
débarquement l'ancien candidat à la
présidentielle a dénoncé la décision de
l'exécutif c'est un signe que nous
donnons à tous les migrants à tous les
passeurs à tous les réseaux qui vivent
sur cette immigration clandestine que
désormais alors que l'Italie ferme peu à
peu ses ports nous nous les ouvrons même
sont de cloche pour Marine Le Pen dans
le Journal du Dimanche elle explique que
ses bateaux doivent je cite retourner à
leur port d'origine appelant la France à
être ferme et à tout mettre en oeuvre
pour les dissuader de tenter la
traversée il y a aussi un jeu de dupes
et une complicité objective entre des
ONG d'extrême gauche comme SOS
Méditerranée qui bénéfice et de
l'extrême gauche pour vous oui bien sûr
juste une association humanitaire et je
pense qu'on devrait d'ailleurs couper
les subventions publiques à SOS
Méditerranée comme lui retirer
l'agrément qui permet aujourd'hui SOS
Méditerranée d'intervenir dans les
écoles Olivier Véran a dénoncé
l'attitude de la nouvelle présidente du
conseil jordjameloni Italie ne tient pas
l'engagement qui était fondamental dans
le mécanisme de solidarité européenne ne
le tiendrons pas notre partie la
contrepartie qui était prévue
c'est-à-dire d'accueillir 3000 migrants
actuellement sur le territoire italien
la France appelle maintenant l'Europe à
se prononcer très rapidement sur les
suites à donner au refus d'Italie
d'accueillir le navire le monitaire pour
Bruno retaillod il faut s'abstenir de
donner des leçons à Giorgia mélodie je
voudrais rappeler et je ne veux pas moi
réhabiliter ni pour ni contre la
présidente du conseil madame Meloni
simplement depuis le début de l'année la
talik est un des pays de première entrée
des voies de migration en France à
accueilli 90 000 migrants l'Europe
devait s'en charger de 8000 pour les
répartir et je crois qu'il y en a eu 117
simplement qui ont été repris donc ça
suffit les leçons de morale la gestion
des flux de migration en Europe fait
débat aussi entre les États membres ça
me dit quatre pays méditerranéens ont
dénoncé la pression qui s'exerce sur eux
au passage ces pays ont dénoncé le mode
opératoire des navires humanitaires
c'est celle du choix de l'Italie et de
la Rép
artition merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
directeurs des rédactions du groupe
Nice-Matin Nice-Matin est donc Var-Matin
vous avez suivi évidemment toute
l'actualité autour de la chaîne Viking
et vous êtes allés prendre la
température du côté italien
oui on est allé prendre la température
du côté italien où les réactions sont
très très tranchées à Vintimille et
autour on dénonce l'attitude de la
France et notamment ce faux procès qui
d'après les Italiens serait fait à la
présidente du conseil géorgia Meloni il
y a peu d'Italiens à Vintimille et dans
la région pour défendre l'accueil des
migrants on nous explique que ça fait 15
ans qu'on subit cette situation qu'il
n'y a pas de solidarité
européenne et que la décision de la
France d'accueillir l'Océane Viking et
quelque part là la moindre des choses et
une manière de partager de partager
l'effort et sur ce que pensent les
parois puisque ce navire a débarqué à
Toulon qu'en pense-t-il Denis
alors là les c'est beaucoup plus partagé
on est allé faire un tour au marché du
cours Lafayette ou certains salut la
décision de la France un toulonné nous a
expliqué je suis je suis fier de cette
de cette décision mais quand on creuse
un peu ce cette position est loin de
faire de faire l'unanimité beaucoup
s'inquiètent et s'inquiète que l'arrivée
de de ce bateau et l'accueil des
migrants à agien créer un appel d'air et
qu'on soit de plus en plus souvent
confronté à cette à ce type de situation
merci Denis merci beaucoup évidemment
toute l'actualité c'est à dire dans les
pages de Var-Matin sur vos sites
internet et on regarde la Une de
Var-Matin les portsmis à la diète fait
doit trouver des solutions face à la
hausse des prix de l'énergie merci
beaucoup de nicaro d'avoir été avec nous
c'est évidemment la question la gestion
européenne de le flux migratoire et
cette décision de l'Italie de George
jamelwy qui a tout déclenché
oui oui bien sûr oui oui non mais ce
qu'il faut dire faut faire une
correction c'est vrai que depuis le
début de l'année il y a eu 86000
personnes qui sont arrivées en Italie
mais sur ces 86000 vous avez une grande
partie qui veulent pas rester en Italie
qui veulent venir en France qui passe
par Vintimille d'où la décision du
ministre de l'intérieur de contrôler
davantage la frontière de Vintimille
pour qu'il y ait moins de passage
selon les nationalités des migrants ils
savent où ils veulent aller pourquoi
parce qu'ils ont de la famille parce
qu'ils savent qu'ils peuvent être
accueillis par exemple pourquoi il y en
a un énormément qui sont d'origine
pakistanaise qui sont d'origine d'Asie
centrale qui veulent aller en Angleterre
parce qu'ils savent qu'ils ont qui
seront accueillis là-bas et c'est pour
ça qu'il y a un goulot si vous permettez
l'expression parce que un goulot
d'étranglement
et encore eu d'ailleurs cette nuit je
crois un bateau qui s'est échoué
au milieu de la Manche parce que on
parle beaucoup de la Méditerranée mais
il y a aussi la Manche et donc vous avez
des routes comme ça alors c'est vrai que
les pays d'accueil enfin les pays de
première accueil comme la Grèce et
l'Italie on a l'impression d'être submer
enfin d'avoir des vagues et que ces
vagues restent chez eux mais elle ne
reste pas chez eux chez elle elle migra
près et Alex il faut qu'on comprenne
bien comment ça se passe ce mécanisme de
répartition au niveau européen alors le
mécanisme actuel de répartition il est
très récent il a été mis en place en
juin dernier à l'initiative d'Emmanuel
Macron et de la présidence française de
l'Union européenne il a été signé par 18
pays sur les 27 de l'Union dont l'Italie
et ce mécanisme il prévoit qu'une fois
que le pays côtier le plus proche a
accueilli le bateau selon les règles
internationales et bien les migrants
sont relocalisés dans les autres pays
européens qui font partie de ce
mécanisme chaque État s'engage sur un
volume de migrants qu'il est prêt à
prendre en charge sur son sol et l'État
qui ne souhaite pas en accueillir doit
verser une compensation financière aux
autres pays qui ont un accueil ça
fonctionne bien ce mécanisme de
répartition alors si on prend l'exemple
de l'océan Viking on l'a vu un jardin a
annoncé qu'au moins les deux tiers des
personnes présentes sur le bateau allait
être relocalisée dans une petite dizaine
de pays européens qui se sont portées
candidats en accueillir notamment
l'Allemagne à l'Irlande et le Portugal
l'Italie a refusé durant cette crise et
le gouvernement italien qui précise un
que depuis la création de ce mécanisme
européen de répartition sur les 8000
migrants accueillis en Italie et bien
seulement 117 l'ont été officiellement
relocalisé dans les autres pays
européens et après l'éclatement de cette
crise italienne à la France a annoncé à
la suspension du transfert des 3500
migrants accueillis en Italie qui
devaient être transférés en France donc
pour l'instant ce mécanisme n'est pas
prêt de fonctionner de temps que
Emmanuel Macron le pensait comme une
étape intermédiaire avant un pacte
européen sur l'asile et l'immigration
mais on en est encore loin on n'est pas
et c'est un serpent de mer est-ce qu'on
peut y arriver à jour à trouver une
vraie politique migratoire européenne et
une vraie politique de répartition ces
migrants qui soient équitables pour tous
les pays
j'espère qu'on arrivera le faire parce
qu'aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup
d'hypocrisies qui règne aujourd'hui on a
confié à des pays comme la Turquie qui
sont pas franchement les champions du
monde de en matière de diplôme de de
droit de l'homme la gestion des flux
migratoires donc c'est quand même un peu
problématique que l'Union européenne est
décédé de déporter des centraliser la
question migratoire à des pays comme
cela donc je pense qu'il faudrait
qu'effectivement l'Europe et ne une
ambition beaucoup plus importante mais
il faudrait déjà que les chefs d'État en
interne soient eux-mêmes convaincus par
l'idée que créer les conditions
d'accueil c'est un sujet pour l'Union
européenne et je me souviens d'Emmanuel
Macron en 2016 dans le gouvernement de
François Hollande s'opposant à Manuel
Valls dans le son de discours de Munich
qui nous expliquait le Premier ministre
à l'époque que la France n'avait plus
les moyens d'accueillir plus personne
sur son territoire et Emmanuel Macron
c'était d'ailleurs montré très généreux
à ce moment-là très humaniste en disant
évidemment que si évidemment qu'il faut
prendre l'exemple sur Angela Merkel
aujourd'hui on peut pas dire qu'il est
créé les conditions justement pour que
nous ayons une politique migratoire qui
soit une politique migratoire de de de
gestion de l'accueil tout à l'heure je
le disais j'ai toujours du mal à
qualifier parce qu'on dit les migrants
ce sont des êtres humains c'est-à-dire
que je le disais même si Yves m'a compté
ça tout à l'heure pour partir que
personne n'est content de partir de chez
de chez lui de son foyer de quitter sa
famille de quitter son environnement
personne n'est jamais personne n'est
content de cela donc en France on a
quand même les capacités je me souviens
à l'époque où je travaillais à regarde
on avait fait un reportage dans une
petite commune de
d'Auvergne un maire de droite qui avait
fait contre la vie de sa municipalité
d'ailleurs décidé de mettre à
disposition des locaux de sa petite
commune rurale pour accueillir des
exilés venant d'un peu partout de du
monde il accueilli plusieurs familles ça
fait évidemment scandale dans la
population qui était une population de
je suis plus 500 ou 600 habitants et au
final et ben ils se sont aperçus de quoi
qu'ils ont pu maintenir une école envie
parce qu'elle était menacée de fermeture
parce qu'il y avait plus il y avait plus
d'habitants des commerces ont réouverts
le club de foot à ouvert etc donc ce que
je veux dire c'est qu'il faut pas
prendre la question migratoire comme
étant un problème sauvé on dit toujours
le problème migratoire non la question
migrat doit être on doit y trouver une
réponse en positif pour tout le monde
parce que évidemment c'est pas c'est pas
on peut pas parler en termes d'utilité
parce que je vois bien le ce que je suis
en train de faire Darmanin en ce moment
nous expliquant qu'il allait falloir
accueillir des migrants pour des métiers
en tension on peut pas penser la
question migratoire on peut pas penser
la question être humain en question en
terme de de matériel et utilité il faut
aussi penser aussi en termes de vie
humaine mais justement là-dessus et pour
terminer est-ce que c'est aussi très
politique pour Emmanuel Macron c'est un
peu aussi ce que pointe Gérard Collomb
dans son interview au point qui a une
différence entre une politique très
ferme de la part de Gérard Darmanin
peut-être plus souple de la part
d'Emmanuel Macron est-ce que c'est un
problème pour lui et est-ce qu'il y a un
risque c'est une décision de faire
monter le rassemblement national en même
temps on a vu la semaine dernière le en
même temps d'un côté on va être très
sévère enfin ils veulent être très
sévère avec les obligations de quitter
le territoire et puis d'un autre côté
ben ils vont accorder des titres de
séjour à des des gens qui pourraient
travailler dans des secteurs